[Musique]
il ya des trucs positifs aussi comme le
matin je me réveille a pas que des tirs
de mortier d'un côté après les policiers
font des bavures policières après on
n'en parle pas de ça et donc à partir du
novembre c'est terminé on dialoguera si
les britanniques veulent dialoguer ou
d'ici là mais on prend des mesures de
rétorsion par ce cas aucune raison qu'on
n'ait pas accès à leur zoo qu'ils aient
accès par exemple à nos ports on a vu
nos yeux les gens qui témoignent en dix
ans on a fait un guet-apens on a
organisé un guet-apens pour faire venir
les pompiers et pour pouvoir les
attaques et après avec cette offre puis
nous ferons les contrôles systématiques
douaniers vétérinaires des contrôles de
sécurité en mer pour les navires
britanniques nous n'aurons aucune
tolérance aucune complaisance on a
commencé d'ailleurs dès cette nuit
ferrière le patrouilleur de la
gendarmerie qui l'a arraisonné la nuit
dernière le corps d'alice geert jan et
ce matin immobilisée sur ce quai du port
du havre
comme
we believe in a
été
contrôlé par les gendarmes puis des
routes et dans la soirée d'hier alors
qu'il naviguait dans la baie de seine sa
faute est revenue pêcher dans les eaux
françaises alors qu'il n'en avait pas le
droit un autre navire britannique a été
verbalisé pour refus d'obtempérer
l'impression qu'ils le sont compris
qu'il fallait revenir à la table de
discussion mais s'ils le font pas on
continuera je vais vous dire ça me
réjouit pas et c'est pas très
intelligent mais avec un partenaire qui
ne comprend que le langage de la force
il faut le parler
un deuxième tour macron le pen vous
faites quoi vous restez chez vous
d'abord le deuxième tour ça sera avec
moi donc je n'y mets écoutez moi parce
que je vois que vous seriez regardez
bien avec 16% des intentions de vote et
bien le polémiste devancerait marine le
pen d'un point ils affronteraient donc
emmanuel macron qui lui est toujours en
tête si cette nouvelle un peu farfelu
peut faire sourire le risque d'une
pénurie de peinture bleue est pourtant
bien là l'alertent a été lancée par un
fabricant néerlandais et les prises très
au sérieux dans l'industrie de la
peinture sur lui la peinture et surtout
la bleue subi de plein fouet comme
beaucoup d'autres secteurs la pénurie
mondiale de matières premières
l'opération azur de rémy d'ail et qui a
en effet été déjoué par les services
secrets personnage important de la
sphère complotistes ce français de 55
ans installé en malaisie voulaient
s'emparer de l'elysée accompagné de ses
partisans et de militaires le paradis du
libéralisme réfléchit à créer un impôt
sur la fortune
je ne veux pas punir ceux qui
réussissent je suis moi-même capitaliste
s'ils veulent être millionnaires
milliardaires continué de s'enrichir
tant mieux mais tout ce que je leur
demande à ce qu'une juge
eut payé votre juste par un peu partout
aux portes de l'europe ces barricades
floris la grèce mais aussi l'autriche la
bulgarie la hongrie la pologne et les
pays baltes au total et sont douze pays
à demander à l'union européenne de
prendre sa part dans le financement de
ces dispositifs
la piste privilégiée par
l'administration maiden est une taxe sur
le patrimoine des plus riches et non sur
leurs revenus le plan de relance
américain coûtera 1750 milliards de
dollars j'ai été très clair il y a une
position commune de longue date de la
commission et du parlement européen sur
le fait qu'il n'y aura pas de
financement de barbelés et 12 juillet
que c'est un clone de l'onu il ya 195
pays les mêmes que ceux qui font partie
de l'onu qui émettent qui élisent des
représentants du diplomate généralement
qu'ils votent ensuite des textes
scientifiques ou qu'ils comprennent
absolument rien l'onu mais fier de vous
présenter franck y francky c'est un dino
à trois jours d'ouverture de la coop 26
les conclusions des rapports souvent non
au oui ça sera d'accord avec ce qu
écrire et scientifique mais ok on prend
parfois l'hypothèse la plus haute par
exemple où la plus dramatique donc j'ai
eu six tâches
c
cnet
un score négatif